all right sway
sway oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally redondo beach
california yep and uh tell me about how
you grew up you had mom and dad
yeah um i was adopted who you were my
biological mom had me when she was 16.
her parents were in a church choir with
my
adoptive mother's sister so
that's how the connection happened um
and a few months later
they brought me home did you ever meet
your
i mean do you remember your biological
mom
actually my biological mom every single
year growing up on my birthday she sent
me a letter
which was pretty cool um and my dad gave
me a birthday present for my first
birthday that my mom still has
it's a super grover from sesame street
with like the cape and everything it was
my favorite
and i met them officially when i was 16.
i was at
a boarding school therapeutic special
situation school in utah we had a
therapy visit
so we flew out to california meet my
therapist and had lunch at islands with
me
my adoptive mom my birth mom and my
birth dad
now it was a trip so how was your
childhood with
my adopted parents honestly pretty
smooth sailing
other than me and my own chaos they
did the best they could and they did
pretty damn good
so your chaos tell me about that
um i mean i was saw psych doctors
since i was six or seven you're right
psych doctor like
since i was six or seven my mom had me
sing one um
they put me on ritalin when i was six or
seven
um and then they also tried concerta
adderall strutera
a whole bunch of fun stuff um
[Music]
yeah yeah so
did you finish high school yes but not
traditionally um
i went to radona union high school uh
for
maybe my whole first year freshman year
but at the end of my freshman year my
gpa was like a 1.7 or something
ridiculously pathetic
and then sophomore year i made it to
about
two months in i guess or maybe the end
of the first semester
before i had to appear in front of
something called the sarb board
student attendance review board um it's
like a
compilation of like principals and cops
and random
people in the neighborhood and [ __ ] like
that um and they basically were like
okay either
you need to get some act right or your
parents need to get some act right so
they were threatening my parents with
jail time
for not making me go to school because
my truancy was uncontrollable
so long story short i got shipped off to
a place in utah
where i literally had no option but to
go to school because
it was in the middle of about [ __ ]
nowhere uh toilet county
uh utah smaller city inside of that
called urda that like no one's heard of
it's like a
thumbprint in the whole state um and
then
there i actually um did really good
like maybe the first month or so i was
really rebellious and [ __ ] like that uh
three months after i got there my father
passed away
so i shut down completely um but then
like one day i just kind of woke up and
decided i didn't want to like feel like
[ __ ] anymore
and i just started like paying attention
and stuff and um i
like flourished in a sense and that's
where you finish high school
yeah and then how did you get introduced
to this
line of work good
question um i mean
i was somewhat
introduced to it like just like like i
mean i was aware of it you get me and
i've been on the streets on and off
since 2010
how are you me 29 year 29
so when i was 18 i was on the streets
the first time
um and then um i mean it was it was
it was it was
okay the option was present and a lot of
people made it known that like like like
you know this
this is something i should do or whatnot
but um i i
had not yet encountered a person that i
wanted to do it with
does that make sense um nobody like like
everyone could spit game right but no
one like like
spit it in the way that made sense in my
mind you know up until recently
oh so you have a pimp
there is a situation for me that
that makes sure i'm safe and all my
needs are met
i understood i understood and
you are you've been doing this for how
long
not long a month or so maybe oh you're
new at this
or i guess you're new at being totally
being
professional yes you've done it before
but now you're
i mean i've i've taken advantage of
certain situations
but i haven't outright like accepted
funds for
favors tell me about the guys that
are your customers um
typical guys yeah i mean honestly i i
for the most part other than a couple
bad eggs like i've gotten really really
lucky with with the people
that um i i encounter
um i got a couple of repeats that are
just really generally really nice people
um and they're on the same page as me
whereas they're paying for the
the leaving afterwards part like that
that's what they're paying for
is for it to just be a short like hello
to your deed and leave
like uh because there's a couple other
people that like were like
you should run away with me and we
should get married and i'll take care of
you and you'll be so
happy like i was like i'm not unhappy
now
so thanks but no thanks you know but um
every once in a blue moon there's a bad
oh [ __ ] sorry
every once in a blue moon is a bad egg
um
my first night out actually um i met a
bad egg
what happened um we were driving and um
he was driving like like way fast away
from the area i try to stay in and when
i try to communicate yo i can't leave
this grid
um he he talked like he was deaf i don't
know if that was like a fake thing or if
he was really deaf
um i know he had the radio on so
typically deaf people don't play music
on their cars kind of sketch but
um when i tried to translate that he
acted like he couldn't hear me and then
he was like type what you're trying to
say i'm not gonna do the voice cause it
sounds so rude okay but he was like type
what you're trying to say like on the
phone or whatnot like
so while i'm doing that he's getting
farther and farther away and then um
when he came to talking about money and
stuff like that
he acted like he's going for his wallet
and he pulls out a knife
um and holds it well this wasn't really
knife it was like a weird like
hand to axe thing it was weird but he
holds it on my throat and then
um tells me if you cooperate you're not
gonna die basically
um so i cooperated because i don't want
to die
um he also showed me that there was a
gun in the car
easily accessible to him um and
i didn't want to do anything with the
creep after that but
i i didn't want to die either you know
or have my face cut or anything like
that so it's just best to just do what
the guy said and be on with it
um so i did and i lived
basically
are drugs a part of your life not as
much as they used to be but i still
dabble
and uh does your does your family know
you're doing this
um outright no
however my mom is not stupid
she's very intelligent and intuitive and
i
i have the notion she's got a hunch
you know but um as far as her and i go
she's basically like like your situation
doesn't make you happy
are you safe check check okay cool i'm
happy for you
i'm so in general are you
happy or now since you've been a little
more committed to this or
absolutely you are my life has changed
immensely in a good way yeah
so you're making more money you're it's
not even about the money
honestly like i mean yeah i'm making
more money but it's
it's more about that whole lifestyle
change and like i feel like i've done a
lot of growing
as a person like um being around
an environment where i have to i have to
maintain a certain um just have to carry
myself a certain way
you me it leaves a lot less room
for for being a [ __ ] [ __ ] up
and a failure you know it's like like i
have to
wake up and face every single day i have
to you know and um
that that's something i need that little
push personally
if i don't have somebody pushing me
along i don't go anywhere
so your your business manager is it
gives you motivation to
keep your appearance up and
um be on top of uh maintain a work ethic
and things like that
yeah for the most part yeah um
and like i i honestly i'm like i use a
lot less drugs
now than i was which is funny because
you'd think i'd be using more because
i've got more money to buy them you know
you'd think like but it's completely the
opposite
um before i was kind of like using dope
as like a
a means to make every day go by as
as easily and quickly as possible but
but i had nothing to do with my day
otherwise you know
so now it's like having a really busy
schedule where i don't have a lot of
time to just like sit on my ass and do
drugs
like like i'm i'm up and i'm out and i'm
busy and i'm happy it's weird it's been
a long time since i've actually
genuinely been this happy all right and
do you have children
huh do you have children um i had um
i was pregnant in 2017 i was about five
and a half months pregnant and i had a
stillborn
i'm sorry yeah
and uh do you have have you been in love
before
yeah um
yeah for them for the most part i've
been interested in uh
females for the most part but every once
in a blue moon there's an exception um
and i'm a weirdo i believe in like uh
past lives and reincarnation and all
that type of fun stuff
and um i'll swear up and down that this
person and i
somehow find each other in every single
life we've lived
over and over and over again like i
believe that
however in this life his mind is not too
kind to him
and he suffers from i don't even want to
call it like schizophrenia or something
because
like like we don't think that's what it
is like i want some other [ __ ]
i think it's the jin have you heard of
the j-i-n-n
no it's um if you google it it's a type
of demon
i guess and it's funny because um a high
percentage of
people who who were diagnosed
schizophrenics
it's believed by professionals that that
they were misdiagnosed as schizophrenia
and it wasn't schizophrenia at all it
was actually the jin
because they all describe the exact same
thing which is a panel of five
or so voices in their mind that comment
on every single thing that they do
and they do something called like like
four truths one lie
so it's like they'll do something
magical to show you their power and gain
your trust
and then they'll totally betray you by
telling you that whoever it is in your
life that you love the most that or you
trust the most whoever
that anchor is in your life they they
destroy your trust for them
um and basically remove that anchor
making it a hell of a lot easier to
devour your soul
so that's what i think is going on with
him i think he's got the gin
uh [ __ ] with him so needless to say
we're not together currently
do you uh do you find this this new
career of yours uh
helps you build self-esteem
absolutely um i mean i've never had
too much of a problem with self-esteem
per se
um but it does help me be confident
um a lot of people think like confidence
and self-esteem go hand in hand
but like to me they differ in a sense
where it's like
like i've always had okay self-esteem
self-worth whatever but as far as like
like
being confident enough to like talk like
proudly without like like being meek or
shy or like like
holding my eyes down to make eye contact
with people to hold my head up when i
walk
you know stuff like that like like that
that's
not been easy to me at all um so
confidence is definitely like like
boosted a whole bunch you've been
arrested
three years yeah wait arrested now since
this yeah since you started doing this
kind of work um i've been arrested but
not for this
um i got i actually was just in jail
yesterday the day before yesterday
uh for like a few hours or whatnot uh
for some old warrants i had
but uh prostitution hasn't put you in
jail no i've had no no prostitution
charges at all yeah
you ever look at the situation you're in
the life that you're leading
and think that you deserve something
different you deserve something better
um
[Music]
i don't know i don't know if i that's
not really the way i think
i'm not the kind of person who's thought
process like i deserve this
like i feel like like whatever you are
worthy of or
whatever you deserve is some you have to
work for it you have to earn it
like so i feel like like oh my wildest
dreams might come true one day you know
and nobody gotta work for
it first so um as far as that goes i
believe i deserve the opportunity to
make that happen for myself
which is basically what i'm taking
advantage of now
dear friends do you have friends
i hope so
um i mean i i have several people in my
life that i
honestly consider friends however the
majority
of people are acquaintances or fair
weather friends as we might say
what have you learned about men from
doing this kind of work
hmm
i don't know if it's so much learning
something new about them as much as it
is
just like gaining more understanding for
them
um being on like uh uh
just having so many personal like
encounters with so many different types
of men
or whatnot like definitely um
breaks my wall down a little bit because
i used to wear like these like blinders
right that when i walked around and this
is something that i picked up just being
homeless and being alone for the most
part um i would have these blinders on
so i wouldn't
stop or pay any mind or attention to any
man that called
out like my or called out for my
attention on the streets or anyone that
like like
whistled or hollered or or even people
just coming at me for something
totally not sex related you know just
people
being polite striking conversation like
i would ignore them i would wear my
blinders and i will pretend like they
didn't exist because
somewhere in my mind i thought like like
every single man is after one thing
and like they just want to use me and
chew me up and spit me out and leave me
like and um that's not the case like
again i've kind of learned like like
it's not even fair for me to think that
i'm being used because
am i not using them as well it sounds
like some of them want to marry you and
that's not using
what's the most important thing you've
learned from doing this
um i've
gained a lot of respect i believe
for um the people in this lifestyle
like a long time ago when i had a lot
less
experience and understanding of this
type of thing
um i would talk so much [ __ ] like you
would catch me saying
oh i respect myself too much to sew my
body
i would never do that i want to be cut
dad those girls must not love themselves
and
just say a whole bunch of [ __ ] that
really wasn't
fair for me to say um and i realized
that now
because like
if i respect myself like i say i do
is it not right that i try to make it so
i
win every time i have sex like like if i
respect myself so much that i'm gonna
give it up for free that makes no sense
like like isn't it more logical to say
that if i have so much respect
and hide myself in such a high regard
that i should
cash out
all right sway well thank you so much
for sharing your story and
yeah i wish you the best of luck with
you and your business manager
thank you
very good
you